what's going on moses what do we got in
this background
what we got here is my dad this is my
dad from the pet
that's a pillow that's messing it up
cause i don't have a green screen solid
green screen effects here
this is the same stuff they use in star
wars this is dad with hair which i have
never seen before yes this is a dad
back in the 80s before i was born he's
taking a call and
i i don't know who he's talking to but
whoever he's talking to he's like
i don't got it this is smooth this is
smooth he's laying down
some some game here on this phone and
that's a full floor suit so
he's absolutely he's very hot you just
went
home to visit your parents but you had
to get out of
new york yeah i was i was here for three
months
uh when it was a hot spot and then i
went down to mississippi
to get out of new york just as
mississippi was becoming a hot spot
i think you might be spreading this your
what's known as the super spreader
either i'm super spreading or i'm like
the tornado chasers of covet
uh yeah just following the hot spot
with none of the science but but you're
not getting any useful footage or
data you're just filming your parents
watching westerns
you know yeah yeah you're you're super
spreading
i've been telling you get out of new
york for a while there
i mean it's because new york is not made
to be inside even a little bit it's not
but i had to wait to get tested before
i'm
and make sure i was uh clean before i
before i moved so i wouldn't spread and
nothing is more humbling than
than realizing you're not famous enough
to get the
early tests uh because while israel's
album was getting tested
i was definitely not i was like well i
just gotta leave it up to the god
the lord or whatever you believe in you
know right
yeah you're a couple projects away from
being because it's gonna be another
thing with the vaccine
it's gonna be the elite yeah
i feel like they're just gonna dangle
the vaccine like above people
and then they're going and they're not
yeah on it we got to get
we got to know someone on the list yeah
it's going to be a it's going to be a
vip club
of like get vaccinated baby
yeah it's not bottle it's vaccine
service it was just kid
super drowsy but some of the school
carries over we got
we are here to take shots you know what
was that what was the test like because
here
i in la you get tested at dodger stadium
and there's so many people going through
that they you do the test you swab it it
feels all
very official and then you put it in a
bag and then you just literally throw it
into
a trash can which just feels like how is
this being
tested at all yeah no they just stick
it's a really long swab
down up your nose into your throat until
your dreams hurt
and then they pull it out and then they
go do their own thing
but then the antibodies they just take
blood like a vampire or a mosquito
and uh that one's easier we're a doctor
some people say doctors take blood more
often
or a doctor or my cousin free because
it's taking blood your cousin's doing
antibody tests
and he's in all type of hustles man
i got savannah bodies i hate the fact
that not
just calling people like you and just
like
running jokes trying to run jokes
casually through conversations
not to say zoom is our new reality uh
the first
zoom birthday party i attended was yours
which was
in a word hectic disaster it was a
beautiful disaster is what i call it
you and everyone and your life that
you've ever met
pushed zoom into its capacity the most
amount of people you could have on zoom
attended your birthday party yeah so we
have people that have
not only never been on zoom but people
have really
never been on the internet
yeah everyone was talking at once
as soon as i got into the into the chat
everybody said happy birthday
but they said at different times so it
just echoed for a long time and
children hopped in because i got baby
cousins
who just like saying happy birthday they
don't even know why they're saying it i
can't remember who was your i tried to
get everyone to sing happy birthday
at the same time but not even knowing
which version
no no counting uh they just all
just start happy happy happy happy
happy birthday and you can imagine
uh how [ __ ] wild that was yeah
also happy birthday is not a great song
happy birthday is a song clearly
written by someone that doesn't want to
sing
because it's so many like you're trying
to get other people to say
happy birthday
just as a sound it's so sad no one wants
to do it it's someone trying to get out
of doing
get other people to join in the happy
birthday song is the slow clap of
birthday of songs in general just
it's just very much that the whole time
uh i'm doing this
[Music]
oh also my mom definitely did
write a sketch and she got kenan and ego
to uh play my real parents
that were stating a case on why they
need to have me
come back to the family honestly
well written um well written
3d level chess type of sketch they
played with a lot of uh
time bending and ultimate timelines
where you were
a baby and that you were adopted at a
certain point the sketch
had legs they truly had legs and it ran
right out of the door
oh somebody we forgot my uncle was djing
at one point while we were trying to
talk
he was like ever ever ever kick it and
then
you know it's like everyone
independently was like
i'm gonna ruin this call i'm gonna make
sure that no one does it i'm gonna bring
all my children on i'm gonna grill oh
i'm gonna try something
one of my answers like ain't nobody even
hearing me
because nobody yeah the whole time you
keep going
you can't hear us and then one of my
kids was just
looking for somebody today she's like
i'm spraying with lysa i'm like that's
not science
it was a lot going on a lot going on
the quarantine birthday is a must go
through it
so you experience it but um speaking of
social change is
obviously very dangerous for you to be
out of protest but it's not like you did
nothing i mean you raised uh what could
only be described as a [ __ ] ton of money
for uh protesters that were protesting
at black lives matter
that might be exposed to covet because
everyone's out there yeah man because
gen z is crazy and not taking no for an
answer and not sitting back and just uh
and just and just you know not sitting
back and being inactive and it's a
beautiful thing
yeah my pops is a high risk so it was it
was cool to do something
that can uh support that while i while i
uh
had to go spend some time with my folks
because they owed her
and yeah i ain't given kobe i mean i
thought
i donated a good mountain that people
have really donated some
amount so basically i put a dollar in
this is crazy i
is it any part of you that thought it
you would raise that much money
not at all man i thought somebody would
do uh
would treat it like jokes and just steal
the idea and go
run and do a bit bigger with a bigger
play
sometimes i i know how to do this i'm
not just some idiot comic that
talks about eating ass on stage there's
like people for this
that people know how to yeah take it but
uh
man yeah it just started building man
and um and it was it was it was uh it
was awesome to see
for sure but also it made me really
nervous because i was like wait
oh wait i gotta give this a what how do
i do that and then
and then that uh between that moment
and uh like a like a month of just
non-stop researching on phone calls
connecting with different organizations
just kind of learning how to
build a mutual aid fund i will say that
i created a job i did not know
uh i did not know i was going to be
working
but i did it and glad and i'm glad um we
get to help
you know what i mean but next time i'll
i'll i'll like research a little
a little bit before you have all these
yeah because it's a lot of money to have
on your
on your hands it's a little yeah i don't
like people playing with my money so i
and that this is a lot of it's a lot of
money yeah i don't want to be playing
with it so
yeah you know the the what the amount is
because
is it still live now yeah it's uh it's
still live it's at 364 the last time i
checked
crazy it's it's insane man it's uh
more than i will make this year so uh
yeah
yeah you'd be investing anymore
really the last thing that we did that
was like a mass gathering was
our show in chicago yeah which is the
nba
all-star game that's right and we did
a team coco house there so really the
last thing we like
i publicly did last irresponsible thing
now in hindsight was
that show in in february oh yeah that
was february but that was february that
was like right around the time
when like we didn't know it was a
pandemic yet
it was just like just scientists and and
educated people knew
but all of us were like no idea it was
valentine's day that's what we did the
show we did the most ill-advised show
no it wasn't the pandemic levels yet it
wasn't pandemic
until like march 9th because i also made
a joke on snl
that uh said black people can't get the
coronavirus how
wrong was i oh boy oh boy
i can't wait to pull up that footage
i've been looking to cancel you for a
long time
amy i've been looking to cancel myself
so we did that show it was on
valentine's day and like bef
so we we had this pre-planned bit of
like let's talk to the crowd about uh
dating advice and then something
happened where you became very newly
single
yeah in a short amount of time so then
we had to give
dating advice to people on stage i was a
very happy relationship still am and
then you were
uh broke yeah fresh
out of a relationship bro broken up with
over text message
so it was uh i was in a to say raw
would be an understatement but perfectly
stated at the same time real rough spot
real rough spot it's like it happened
that day uh that's how it kind of
some of your advice to the crowd if i
remember was anna man just hold
on to her i think i think the last
uh the last joke i said was just a tear
falling
onto the stage how fitting for the times
bobby was saying you called it i did